we are delighted to bring you this
seminar presented by labyrinths
welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's keynote
presentation
titled individualized health it is my
pleasure to introduce you to dr michael
snyder
stanford asherman professor chair of
genetics director
of the center of genomics and
personalized medicine
dr snyder received his phd training at
the california institute of technology
and carried out post-doctoral training
at stanford university
his laboratory study was the first to
perform a large-scale
functional genomics project in any
organism and has developed
many technologies in genomics and
proteomics
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in a q a box
our speaker will respond back to you via
email
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
please join me in welcoming dr snyder i
will now turn the presentation over to
him
well thanks for having me here today i
want to tell you about our research
that's trying to use big data
to improve health care so i'm going to
start with a premise that may offend
many of you which is the way we perform
health care these days
is entirely wrong the next slide shows
what i mean by that basically if you
look on the left
currently medicine is really focused on
treating people and they're ill
as such it's very reactive we typically
measure very few things when people are
healthy
also when people are healthy the
frequency with which you measure them is
very rare
and nearly every decision about your
health care is based on population based
measurements
i'll argue that we should really be
focused on keeping people healthy
let's let's be very proactive we're
capable of measuring many many more
things than we currently do
the frequency i'll argue should depend
on what your disease risk is and and
your personal trajectories as you're
seeing following various biomarkers and
perhaps most importantly nearly every
decision about your health should be
based on individual based measurements
not on population based measurements
and as such we should really be focused
on precision health
now to illustrate this point for the
next slide
this is a exercise i derived from
stephen seinhubel
basically you're probably taught that
your average or
your oral temperature is 98.6 and in
fact if you look at studies and this is
one of
a number of them out there this is from
fairly large study 3000 people first of
all that number is wrong it's not 98.6
in fact 97.5 is a little bit more
uh likely to be the median value but
perhaps more
more importantly uh it turns out if you
look at the bottom of the box that's the
25th quartile so the 25th quartile is
94.6
and the 75th quartile is 99.1 so there's
a range
and so in today's world if your normal
baseline temperature
is 94.6 you go to a physician's office
today and they measure you at 98.6
they'll tell you
everything's fine you're perfectly
healthy what are you doing here go home
but in fact you're up four degrees over
your baseline i guarantee you're not
healthy you're probably quite ill
and there's no way they would know that
because they don't
know your individual baseline so this is
why i would argue it's really really
important to know your healthy baseline
and then you'll be able to better detect
disease in you
rather than from using population-based
measurements
so that's the theme i'm going to hammer
many times throughout this talk
now i'm sure you know your health is
dependent on many different things we
know intuitively it's dependent on your
genome
and all these other items that are
listed on the slide as well so the
bottom left your
environmental exposures stress food
exercise these all will impact your
health
and we're now in an ear where it's
possible to quantify these things so we
can understand in quantitative terms
what sorts of things might impact your
health especially in light of your
particular genetic composition
so that is to say based on your genome
sequence you can see which variants
might expose you
to certain kinds of predispositions that
will also become accentuated
with environmental or lifestyle factors
so we can now measure as i say most of
these although it's somewhat clunky
but nonetheless we can measure their
biochemical effects by actually looking
at our blood and urine and looking at
the various analytes
and so as many of you may know a number
of years it's actually over 10 years ago
now we set up something we call
personal mixed profiling and the key
elements of this are we actually get
we do big data measurements on a group
of people it's 109 people
who i'll tell you about in a minute we
do deep
oh mix measurements and we follow them
longitudinally those are the key aspects
so in its most deluxe form we'll follow
uh 14 different elms the genome
but then all these other ohms as well
many of them like the epigenome that's
being methylation and transcriptome
those will be measured out out of your
immune cells called peripheral blood
monocyte cells
and then many of the other things listed
there like the protium and cytokines and
metabolites and lipids
those are all measured out of your
plasma in some cases like metabolites
and lipids we measure those out of your
urine as well
we also measure the microbiome so as i
say in the most deluxe form we'll
measure 14 different atoms on people but
for the most part we're measuring about
seven or eight ohms
in addition to that we have deep
clinical testing we run
questionnaires as people get sampled uh
on the left side we actually have smart
watches on people we put
about seven years ago and we also run a
number of advanced teslas stress echoes
glucose control measurements because
we're very interested in type 2 diabetes
as you'll see a little bit later
and how people become type 2 diabetic
and so we have a lot of measurements
there
and in fact this cohort um it actually
turns out it's a typical u.s cohort we
thought we were reaching it for type 2
diabetics in the sense that
nine percent of the folks who entered
are type 2 diabetic
and a number and a number of others
roughly about 35
to 40 percent for pre-diabetic as you'll
see in a minute
and the key element out of this is that
we're actually sampling these this
cohort in general is pretty healthy
aside from some of them having elevated
glucose
and sugar uh and so we're following them
longitudinally that's a very very key
aspect we sample them
sorry quarterly when they're healthy and
then when an adverse event comes along
like a viral infection
or maybe a colonoscopy we'll typically
take five to seven
additional samplings so we're trying um
to understand
what happens when people are healthy so
what does a healthy profile look like
how does it differ amongst different
people how does it change over time
and equally importantly what happens
when people become ill
can we see the changes that occur and
how extensive are they
and in particular how do people react to
different adverse
conditions like viral infections things
like that
and so as i say we've been following
this group by john 1 of the cohort we've
been following me for over 10 years
but most of cohort we've now been
following a little bit over seven years
some more some less
and so we've collected quite a bit of
data on these folks over time so
why are we doing this again we're trying
to understand what what it means to be
healthy and how people differ from one
another
but we also want to know whether these
advanced technologies
can really be used to better manage
people's health can we use these
to better catch disease early make risk
predictions things like that
so i'm going to jump right to the punch
line with regards to this last question
it turns out that by following people
for a little over three years just for
the first part of the study
we made 49 major health discoveries
if you count hypertension the number
rises to 67.
and they come in all kinds of different
areas so it wasn't like we're focused on
cardiovascular but we saw
cardiovascular hemoncology metabolic
discoveries as well and so 49 of 109
that's almost
half the folks had something very very
important they learned about their
health
if we look just down at the bottom part
in the hemonc
area we caught someone with early
lymphoma i'll show examples of this in a
minute
two people with pre-cancers one's called
mgus another smoldering myeloma
some folks are thalassemias in the upper
right part we basically found two people
with serious heart issues one from
genomics one from
actually wearable devices black scenario
things like this
metabolic disorders were picked up as
well
so on and so forth and the key element
out of all this is that
no one of these technologies found all
these it really took the combination
of different technologies to be able to
re reveal these health discoveries
and so we think they all add value and
ultimately we'd like to see some form of
this i'll come back to this a little bit
later
uh incorporated into healthcare now
of these different technologies as i say
they all had value
but one that started off with a lot of
value was in fact the genome sequence
just from the first 70 people we had 12
that learned something very very
important
for their health and as an example one
of the 12
had a mutation in a gene called bracket
one
so you probably know that brachy genes
predispose people to breast and for
women ovarian cancer
and so one of the individuals did in
fact have this and they will get
increased screening as a consequence of
this
three people learn something very very
important for their health
one person if you look down the list
you'll see that rbm 20.
one person had a mutation in a
cardiomyopathy gene
and once you know what it turns out they
actually pretty young person they had a
heart defect which was picked up in a
subsequent stress echo
and they're on medication now as a
consequence
you look at the very top line two people
where it says 2x
that means two different people each had
mutations in that gene called
sdhb that mutation predisposes people
to certain kinds of cancers and tumors
and once you know one of those
individuals as a whole body mri
turns out had early thyroid cancer which
was caught
and that part was removed the match were
able to maintain
most of the thyroid so they don't need
thyroid replacement therapy
and finally uh as i mentioned there were
actually nine
pre-sorry nine diabetics in the study
they were all thought to be type two
but one individual if you look at the
the um
case last from the bottom hnf one a
that actually person turns out that they
were thought to be type 2 but it turns
out they have a mutation in a modi gene
and that's a very different kind of
diabetes than type 2 diabetes so in fact
this is a modi case and they've been on
the wrong medication for years we also
found some with a very very important
variant that affected a drug they were
taking so the bottom line out of this
was that we had 12 and 13 if you count
the the pharmacogenetic finding
13 people who learned something very
very important from
from their genome and in several cases
it really had
critical impact on their health and the
drugs they're currently taking
so to show you a few other examples um
this is a case at the top of a person
with early lymphoma that was actually
picked up with imaging
they had a large plane if you look at
top right it turns out their spleen was
much larger than
normal and they also had several other
biochemical markers that were off
the bottom part there were two people i
mentioned who had pre-cancers these are
picked up with biochemical assays
one individual also a fairly young
person turns out they'd given two
samples
and those two samples had very very high
levels
of a protein called igm it's an antibody
and it was just way higher than the
other thousand samples that are at the
bottom of the plot there
so they were just way off relative to
everyone else and then follow-up studies
revealed that sure enough
they actually had a pre-cancer and this
is a big deal because they'll get
screened more frequently
to see if they'll convert to aggressive
cancer and
that could get caught at a much earlier
stage with this information
we also had six people who had plaques
in their artery that's shown here
i'm actually one of the six uh these are
relatively
modest but it's kind of useful to have
caught this because
the follow-up is that they should have
their statins increase that was true for
me
my plaque is now dissolving so again
this was very useful information to find
as i mentioned before there is a big
emphasis on trying to understand type 2
diabetes
and we did have nine people who thought
they were diabetic when they entered the
study
that's on the left bar in the blue so
not
nine or eight point four percent but it
turns out two people are diabetic who
didn't know it
they found out when they entered the
study and then
quite a few people became diabetic
during the study in fact nine
additional folks were clinically
classified as type 2 diabetic
as the study progressed and others had
diabetic range values but what we were
very interested here was understanding
how do these folks become type 2
diabetic that's never really been
explored before people just going to get
classified
but how do they actually get there and
it turns out that
um
sorry this uh showing online maybe we
could click
on this here tyler something's funny
we're missing a panel uh
it's an animation this is inside ten
yeah sorry about that you'll have to cut
after this part
so do you see that you can animate but i
cannot apparently
you don't see that so the right side
shows my mini panel
but i didn't catch that before but it
doesn't show in the big panel
yeah there it is okay so can we start
here
uh yeah
do you want to start from the top of the
chair
yeah when i start from the top of ten
okay okay you ready do you want to keep
the slide like it is right now
i think so then we don't have to worry
about clicking through it if that's okay
with you
okay yeah no problem let me go ahead and
catch you down then from five
and then you can start from the top of
ten
alrighty starting in five four
three two
we also had a number of people who were
diabetic as i mentioned before nine were
thought to be diabetic when they ended
study
and it turns out that when we looked at
this further when they first enrolled we
discovered two others were diabetic who
didn't know it so
in fact 11 were diabetic at steady entry
and we're very interested in how do
people become type 2 diabetic so if you
look at the left side
the blue part it turns out that nine
others in addition the first nine nine
others became clinically diabetic
during the course of the study and
others had diabetic range values
as i say we're very interested in how do
people become type 2 diabetic that had
never been
explored before and by the way a lot of
people were pre-diabetic and i had no
idea that's not surprising 9 out of 10
pre-diabetics have no idea
i guarantee a lot of you watching this
video are pre-diabetic spiking your
glucose away
and have no idea anyway and then others
became pre-diabetic during study
but we're very interested in how to
become type 2 diabetic and
it turns out as i say there were nine
who became clinically classified
of those nine two got there through
weight gain that's the classical way
people gain weight the microbiome
diversity drops
and their glucose goes up and that's how
two individuals became diabetic
but several seven others did not gain
weight yet still became diabetic
in five of the cases they just gradually
became diabetic and if you look on the
right side the bottom two plots
the orange line is in fact fasting
glucose and the gray line is actually
hemoglobin a1c
and then there are these numbered blue
dots those are actually oral glucose
tolerance tests and in the bottom right
plot
that individual was first classified by
oral glucose tolerance
thus they had very high values they were
spiking the glucose
the one in the middle actually was first
classified by fasting glucose when they
went out of range
and they steadily became that's true for
both of those folks
but there were two additional people who
didn't gradually become diabetic in fact
they spiked their way there i'm one of
the two in fact the top
left is me so initially that's about
eight years of data sitting there maybe
a little bit more
initially i first became if you look at
the left side
type two diabetic after a nasty viral
infection respiratory syncytial virus
and i happen to go in to the physician
because of my genome i
predicted it actually and they went to a
physician to get it measured uh i was
actually getting
uh something that would measure insulin
resistance what we discovered is my
glucose is
abnormally high and actually followed
but it was very clear it
spiked into diabetic range that little
bump on the left it looks small but it's
over a year of data
uh in fact i had to change my lifestyle
i cut out
all my sugars and i had been biking but
doubled my biking started running and i
actually got it down to normal range
like it was so boringly low that i
stopped looking at it
and then i really didn't look at all
somebody else looked at it if you're
looking about in the middle of the plot
somebody else looked at and said
mike your hemoglobin a1c is 7.1 you're
back to type 2 diabetic again so i had
no idea
so they sampled me a few times i stopped
running and you can guess when see where
it says viral infection on that second
one
i'd actually stopped running that so
it's not clear whether the viral
infection or the lack of running
uh caused that spike in in glucose and
hemoglobin a1c
uh but anyway it spiked up again
and so after it got up to that seven
range i started running i could get it
down never
all the way down the baseline and then
it gradually just kept
increasing so um what i did
as a consequence was i had been running
quite a bit uh
that's how i got it from seven one down
to about five seven
and it just gradually kept creeping up
even over the years and
um was probably running about as much as
i could
four days a week uh roughly four to five
miles a run
uh and it nonetheless it kept creeping
up and so
about three years ago i switched from
running to actually weightlifting
because i had heard muscle mass was
better for glucose homeostasis
and i thought that would help but
actually did it kept creeping up with
the same slope
so in fact that didn't work
and then finally i said well it's time
to bite the bullet i took uh
metformin which is what you normally
would take for type 2 diabetes
and i did in fact take that and once you
know it i'm a non-responder
so in fact my glucose kept going up all
the way to 7.5
and i'm like oh no this is trouble so
what i did i i wasn't sure what to do
next and
actually had other data and that's what
really revealed what was going
on it turns out that we can measure this
complicated graph but we can measure my
glucose
disposition rate as we did for everyone
else in the study
and what we discovered is that i'm
actually insulin sensitive
which is a little unusual for a diabetic
uh i'm also
making insulin just fine so what's wrong
with me
and my cells respond insulin i make
insulin
well it turns out i don't release it
from the pancreas properly that does
happen it's not that common
and so my glucose disposition i'm one of
these people at the very very bottom
where i actually very very slow about
getting rid of my glucose out of my
blood because i'm not releasing my
insulin from the pancreas
and it turns out there's a drug for that
it's a pranding derivative
called repentalide and it turns out with
this information i
took that and it worked like a charm it
drove from 7-5 down to 6-3
within a few months so that's a really
good sign and
all this worked out because i actually
can figure out what was wrong with me
and so this is what we call precision
diabetes the the goal is to know
exactly what's wrong with people so you
could treat people with the right drug
and get the right outcome this this drug
i'm taking it's not a second or third
line drug it's much further down the
list
and so it's probably very helpful in my
case because i know exactly
what's wrong with me and so i can drill
in on that quickly so we would argue
that this kind of information should be
done for
everyone quite frankly this is not a
hard test to do
to figure out how people are diabetic
and maybe we can put people
on the right drugs better now one of the
most important things we've learned so
far from the study is actually
summarized on this slide
what we've discovered is that in fact
people have very strong personal
characteristics
so no matter which ohm we use whether
it's your metabolism your
proteome your microbiome cytokines
clinical labs
you actually have very very strong
molecular characteristics and they don't
change that much over time
so what this slide is showing just for
simplicity it's showing 12 people with
at least 10 healthy visits
and every dot is a different visit every
color is a different person i'm the
light blue person it's about six years
of data for me
and what you'll notice is that people
cluster according to their own
profiles they're they're generally again
the blue dots are together the red dots
for that person are together
the brown dots that's a different person
they're all together and they don't
change that much over time even with six
years of data
now the transcriptome i know looks a
little more jumbled but if i were to
show you that three dimensions
you'd get the same result so the point
out of this is that
we all have very very strong molecular
profiles
and they actually don't change that much
over time
moreover it turns out if you undergo
some sort of serious perturbation say a
viral infection
we've shown by exercise we've now done
this by a lot of different ways
this one here is actually people did a
weight gain weight loss
if you undergo one of these we call them
perturbations you will shift your
profile
no question your microbiome change your
metabolism but you will still look more
like you
than anyone else so these profiles are
very very robust and that's shown here
this is just looking at microbiome after
weight gain weight loss
there are nine people here each color is
a different person we
again clustered them by similarities in
this case
microbiome and they cluster by person so
you'll notice at the bottom the green
person clusters together above it's the
brown person
all these folks did a weight gain weight
loss they actually gained on average six
and a half pounds
but um again they didn't shift their
they shifted microbiome a little bit
but they still look more like them than
anyone else
so why is this a big deal well we think
this is why you need these personal
longitudinal measurements if you're
trying to just compare your
disease status relative to everyone else
that signal
is tough to find and that's because your
personal profiles again are so strong
that you can't really your disease state
and your healthy state are closer
together
than your disease state for you closer
to everyone else's disease state for the
most part there are some exceptions
so the point out of all this is that
this is why the g wasp guys need
tens of thousands of cases and tens of
thousands of control because that signal
uh is very very small when you're trying
to look at disease versus not disease
it's much much smaller than if you look
in the same person
where you see their healthy baseline and
find their disease state
there you can't miss that signal you
can't miss that delta
and if you think about it that's what
precision medicine is all about
individualized medicine and health we
want to understand
at a personal level when people shift
and you're you're going to have a hard
time finding that
from these population-based measurements
so this is why these longitudinal
profiles get your healthy baseline
profile
now while you're healthy so you can
follow them your disease when it does
shift
now as i say these profiles are
generally quite stable and that that is
true
but they will gradually change there's a
few molecules that will change over time
and because we've been sampling people
so much we can actually see
what markers are changing like on the
same people
over time and it turns out that
at a cross-sectional level meaning look
at old folks and young folks
we will see plenty of markers that are
different between old people and young
people
and we find a lot of the same markers
people have described already
but we find a whole lot more but most
importantly
in the same person we can see exactly
how they're changing
aging over time and this is just two
examples i'm the guy on the left
there's someone else on the right some
person one which is me
it turns out i'm a pretty typical ager
it turns out that
my coagulation system the molecules
shift up over time that's known already
some of my metabolic markers are
changing
um and liver and kidney markers actually
also
you know gradually changing over time um
but the cool thing is you can measure
this in an actionable time frame meaning
you can actually do it within two years
see how people are aging
the person on the right it turns out
their major pathways that are aging are
actually
cardiac pathways so their heart pathway
is actually shifting over time
in a very statistically significant
fashion most of these
markers for heart function are changing
so we had enough people we had 43 people
that we could actually see how they were
aging on time and we said well what are
some of the major categories
by which people age and so using
informatics we could group people
into four what we call agent type so
agent type is how you're aging now
they're more than
four just with their four major classes
they got teased out when you only have
43 people
and some people the top part there are
kidney agers
liver agers the second line each column
by the way is a different person
each row is their age of type for that
function so kidney liver metabolic
immune and so some people if you go all
the way to the right
some people are aging in all four
categories
if you look at the right most boxes
that's got a red box around it that
person is liv
is aging in three categories liver
metabolic immune function but not so
much in kidney
and then if you go all the way to the
left boxes the one all the way to the
left that person
is the left box is a kidney a metabolic
age or and the one next to that that
person's a kidney ager and so on and so
forth so the point is
we can see exactly how people are aging
and
we think some of this information is
clinically actionable because
some of the markers in this are actually
clinically actionable markers
and in fact there are a total of um
six clinically actionable markers
although we think the biochemical
pathways are a better description of
what's going on but nonetheless
for these clinically relevant markers
that are shown here
we can follow at a personal level how
people are aging
and so the left one is this hemoglobin
a1c a measure of diabetes and glucose
function
and if you look at the rightmost bar
there so within each box there's a bar
with a
with a red dot over it that's actually
what the group as a whole is doing
they're they're actually going up in
their hemoglobin a1c
their bun which is uh neutrophils
creatinine there's
is what the third box is um should be
creatinine not creatine
they're actually everybody's going up
and this is known already this happens
over time
but if you look at individuals if you
look at the bars like
just look at hemoglobin a1c what we've
discovered
is that some people uh are going up as
you would expect
but there's actually some people who are
going down that is to say
they've actually decreased this
metabolic marker and that's a good thing
in the case of hemoglobin a1c and in
some cases we have a molecular
explanation for this they actually
started exercising or they lost weight
or what have you so for the case of
hemoglobin a1c we could actually explain
it
and this is kind of cool because what it
means is if we define your agent type
you can take action and you can change
that which is pretty
good we think now over on the third box
it's creatinine
it turns out all those dark bars those
people are statistically significantly
dropping in their creatinine
which is a measure of kidney function so
they're improving their kidney function
which is pretty cool it's not clear
what's going on there but there are 10
folks that
have statistically significantly
improved their kidney function
and eight of those eight of the ten are
actually on statins
so we think that this is um something
about statins that's probably
improving their creatinine function it
might be related to the
muscle mass and things like that but
we don't notice anything obviously
perhaps they're also improving their
kidney function
so the point out of all this is that for
the first time we can see
at a personal level how people are aging
and then
actually it's potentially actionable uh
and if you think about it there's a ton
of supplements out there
that are on the market you have no idea
what's good and what snake oil
and you would have no way with current
technology of figuring out
how you're aging the telomeres they just
change too slow they're too noisy
it's a terrible assay for aging whereas
with these personal aging markers you
can actually see for the first time how
they're aging you can
actually act on it and see if you're
reversing any of those
so this is um a lot of the in-depth
omics profile that we've been doing it's
it's really turned out to be quite
powerful
now one issue that comes up a lot is you
know how do you scale this thing and so
uh here's where i'm totally conflicted
but we formed a company
called q-bio that's actually um
basically doing a medical version of
this
of ipop as we like to call it so it's
it's spun out and and it's it's
not collecting as much data but it's
more medically actionable data
and so it does deep profiling people
longitudinally
and it also does whole body mri which
the
research project we're doing the ipop
one is not to
and even right off the bat we've done
just from the first hundred or so pieces
we've done many more now
participants i should say we found some
pretty important things so for example
and it often takes multiple measurements
one measurement doesn't always do the
trick but
like we caught some of early stage
leukemia another person with fatty liver
and diabetes
uh we caught someone prostate and
ovarian cancer
and not only that just like an eye pop
the longitudinal data is very very
valuable because if you can see how
people are changing
uh you can actually see what's going on
so as one example we actually caught
some
early pancreatic cancer by following
their changes and that's a big deal many
of you probably know pancreatic cancer
is lethal
so finding this early stage we would
argue is a super big deal
so um the bottom line is we i know it's
so expensive you have to pay thirty five
500
for this uh i think this is just how it
starts but i'm sure we can get it much
much cheaper
but we think this this concept of
bringing these advanced technologies to
better follow people while they're
healthy will be huge for improving
health care
and so this is an area that we're really
trying to push out there
now one important aspect of what we're
doing is is actually the wearables and
it's very relevant
in today's pandemic actually so um
many of you may know there's a lot of
wearables out there now and at the time
the slide was made which was about a
year ago there's over
400 of these devices and they measure
all kinds of things if you look at the
right side
don't measure your activity meaning your
steps running that sort of thing and
measure your heart rate
skin temperature sleep blood oxygen so
on and so forth they measure
all kinds of different things and so the
way you use these is
somewhat similar to omix profile but
what's powerful about them is they're
they're measuring things on a continuous
basis
so the way you use these is actually you
start getting people's patterns
and then you look for deviations from
those patterns
and so looking here this is actually my
profile
um this is looking at sleep on the top
heart rate in the middle skin
temperature at the bottom
you can see i sleep at night i wake
during the day occasionally on that
that's
a little bump in there and back to sleep
at night heart rate is low
at night high during day back down at
night skin temperature which is
different from oral temperature
for most people it's high at night comes
down during the day goes back
up and so on and so forth so you can
actually determine people's patterns
and so as i say we've been using these
as health monitors following people's
patterns
and it turns out it's pretty cool for me
one of the biggest deviations
is actually uh it turns out when i
drop my blood oxygen on airline flights
it turns out that's true for everyone
that's a whole separate study i can tell
you about that later but the point is
actually that when you fly on aircrafts
your blood oxygen will drop
now it turns out that this is also very
very powerful
for picking up disease and i'll show you
one example this is very very relevant
for today's pandemic so what we
discovered is that we can figure out
whether you have respiratory and other
kinds of disease using a simple pulse ox
and smart watch
and so in fact i figured out my lyme
disease from just that
so the back story behind this is i was
helping my brother put up fences in
rural massachusetts
and then two weeks later i was flying to
norway through frankfurt
and on that last flight which is a low
altitude plane if you look at the left
normally on these low altitude planes uh
these small regional jets as i like to
call them
basically your your blood oxygen will
drop but it doesn't drop all that much
drops about 96 or so 95 96
then when you land it comes back to
normal on this particular flight my
my medium blood oxygen was 90 i measure
myself all the time as you probably
figured out
and when i landed thinking back to
normal is 95 or 96 so it was abnormally
low
and i also noticed that my heart rate
was elevated at the time
and then later learn my skin
temperatures off if we look at the
the right side these are low resolution
measurements
of that so the top is heart rate daily
heart rate the bottom is
uh skin temperature and is laid out
schematically but basically i realized
that
again my heart rate was elevated uh i
later got a low grade fever i went to
a physician in norway i warned him it
might be lyme disease because of the
timing
and he actually drew blood uh and and
so my monocytes are up and said yep
you've got a bacterial in this case
spirochete infection
uh he recommended i take penicillin i
said no i need doxycycline
and it was tense for a few moments there
but he did give in give me give me the
doxycycline i cleared it right up and
then
when i got back uh it was roughly 10
days later
i basically had my blood drawn sure
enough i was lying positive
and it's a very well controlled
experiment i happened to have given
blood several days before i left i was
lying
negative so i'd see it converted during
that time so the point out of all this
is that i was able to pick up my lyme
disease
from a simple smart watch and pulse ox
which measure your blood oxygen
and so that prompted us to look at all
the different days i've been wearing my
smart watches about two years of date at
a time now it's about seven years a day
maybe eight years i guess it's eight
years we have a ton of data
and the point out of all this is that uh
when
if you look at the left side here it
turns out during the two years i've been
wearing the smart watch
there were five sorry there were four
times when i got ill there's the line
time those are the triangle days if you
will
and there were two times when i had a
definitely a viral infection that star
in the square at the bottom we now know
it's a viral infection
and the one with the circle was the time
when i was actually ill i had high
c-reactive protein or crp
but they didn't report being ill so
wasn't necessarily
strongly symptomatic to the point where
he called being healed but turns out my
crp was just as high
as any of those other times and the
point out of this plot is that if you
look at what's there
every single time i was ill with high
crp
i had a higher percentage of outlying
skin temperature
and heart rate every single time and so
the point out of this is that
skin temperature and heart rate can tell
you when you're getting sick
we think just because you'll have these
a higher fraction of outlying
measurements
and you can do it by other means as well
so that prompted us to write an
algorithm that we call
change of heart and we think we can use
it to tell when people are getting ill
before they realize it because what
happens is your heart rate goes up
before you're symptomatic before you're
congested and such
and so on the right side those are what
we call delta plots they're
a change from your resting heart rate
you can see
they go up you see those little red
arrow heads
they basically show where you see this
change from resting heart rate
and it's always ahead of when people are
symptomatic and certainly by the time
they gave blood and so
i was these four times we saw every
single time
and then we had three people one of them
got sick twice
and it turns out the algorithm works
great on them so it doesn't work
so well for skin temperature we think
because people wear the wall
um somewhat some where it loosely works
for me i wear mine type
it doesn't work for anyone but the heart
rate works for everyone
so we're now actually as you might
imagine running a clinical trial love to
have any of you listening join that
trial
if you have a smart watch or wearable
please sign up
uh you can find it from our website look
for innovations
lab uh and or just write to me and i'll
i'll steer you too it will enroll you in
our study
and the goal is to really see if we can
tell when people are getting sick and
we're specifically gearing it towards
kevin 19 but
for any illness we want to be able to
see if we can tell when people are
getting ill
before they realize it and maybe they'll
even pick up some of the asymptomatic
folks like i was for one of my
infections so we'll see
okay so we think again smart watch is
going to be very very powerful health
monitors in the future
we've also done a lot in other areas
i'll tell you a little bit about that
we've done quite a bit with glucose
monitors that's shown here
we've been because of my high interest
in type 2 diabetes and our cohorts
uh very geared in that direction so it
turns out that we
put these these things called glucose
continuous glucose monitors you put them
on you they they stick on you a little
bit like a tb test but
you don't take them off you leave them
on there for roughly two weeks
and basically uh we put these on normal
people
pre-diabetics and a few diabetics and
what we've discovered is that you know
people have different
patterns so the spike or the
medium middle one's a moderate spike and
the bottom one's the severe spike
so we call these glucatite textures
you'll see in a minute
and so it turns out that there's a lot
of people running around who think
they're perfectly normal they're very
very severe spikers
and so we've written algorithms we take
those patterns we write algorithms and
then we
classify people into glucotypes again
either
low glucotypes if you look at the bottom
side
they either don't spike much the low
glucotypes moderate spikers in the
middle
very very severe spikers at the top i'm
a severe spiker
so we can classify people into these
patterns
so the next slide um it turns out that
different people will spike to different
foods this is also shown by aaron
seagull
where some people we put people on
standardized meals and and
as one example some people spike to
peanut butter and bread
others are protein bars some develop
some just one of those
nearly everybody spikes the corn flakes
of milk we think that's like poison
so i actually think it probably should
be outlawed it's probably worse than
smoking but
uh the point is that that's a nasty one
it'll spike your glucose from most
people for 80 percent of people
and this next slide is a little
complicated but um
what was very powerful from our study is
that we discovered with these continuous
glucose monitors
there are normal people people who
measure normally if you look at the
right side who are
thought not to be diabetic by either
fasting glucose hemoglobin a1c
uh or even oral glucose tolerance test
so it turns out they're very very severe
spikers
they don't have good good glucose
control so we think these devices are
going to be very very powerful
for being able to help catch people who
are
uh in this boat it's actually a very
different kind of assay than
than any of the other standard assays
and so i think it still pulls out
glucose cis regulation it just does it
by different assay and and we think this
is going to be really really powerful
uh for being able to catch pre-diabetics
and help them better manage
their their glucose control and these
devices by the way they're over the
counter in europe they're actually
um you have to have a physician order
them in the u.s but
my own guesses will become over the
counter here soon too
so the last wearable i want to tell you
about is a new one we've been working on
it's actually the explosometer so i
mentioned before your health is due to
many things and i felt we could measure
most of these things
pretty readily with the exception of the
lower left
in general we really don't know what
we're getting exposed at a personal
level all of you watching
this video right now we're getting
exposed to all sorts of biological
and chemicals you have absolutely no
idea
what you're what you're breathing in so
what we did was we
we started looking at airborne exposures
we took an existing
exposometer which measures particulates
pm 2.5
as well as temperature and humidity and
we re-engineered it this is the latest
version i hope you can see this
but this this version actually uh sucks
up there it's actually twice as much as
the original one but so the original one
basically brings in about um
the equivalent of what an average person
uh a breeze about 1 15 what an average
person
breathes and so what we're doing is we
we've re-engineered this to
under the intake valve has a pump under
the intake valve we have a filter that
captures all the particulates and
biologicals
and under that we have a chemical
absorbent that will absorb all the
chemicals in the air
and what we do is we we actually take
these samples they're personal monitors
people wear them they take them
longitude we take samples longitudinally
and typically for me
what we'll do is sample uh once during
the week take so
sample continuously during the week one
during the weekend
and then every time i go to a new
location i'll have a different device so
we can actually sample
from all around the world wherever i've
been traveling
and so what we'll do is we'll collect
these samples
we figure out all the biological
someone's exposed to by doing deep
next generation sequencing so we take
off we elude off
all the biological material sequence all
the rna and dna
quite deep as you'll see in a minute we
actually figure out what chemicals
people are exposed to by
eluding off the the chemicals and
running a mass spectrometry
and then we analyze the data and in the
first study we did we're now running
this a lot deeper
shown here there are three people who
were profiled for
quite some time i'm p1 i uh
i actually been doing this now for
almost eight years but from the first
two years of data we collected data over
two years the color codes are by seasons
uh p2 wore the device for about a year
b3 for about three months and then we
have some very
strategic targeted experiments we did as
well i'll tell you that in a minute
and so what we do is we collect these as
i say from
the different individuals this is p1 p2
and p3
uh and and most of samples again are
collected in the bay areas you might
imagine so lower left there
but uh we can also get samples from all
around the world again
and because i travel a lot we have
samples from all around the world
and as they say what i'm going to do is
tell you about both the biologicals and
chemical exposures people have
been exposed to so as i mentioned we
sequenced quite deeply
to figure out the biologicals and in
total we went up
doing over 70 billion reads it's really
quite a deep data set
about 30 million on the rna per sample
and 40 million on the
on the dna side
and what we've discovered is that over
2500 different species
are detected amongst the whole group but
it's quite a few even for one person so
the one person wearing the exposometer
for three months
had over a thousand species i've had
over 2000 from the first two years of
data so
you really expose a vast wealth of
microbes and other things out there
and we've looked at this in detail
that's shown here
so on p1 there's p2 there's p3 and this
is just at the kingdom level
each color code's a different kingdom so
red is bacterial
that brownish color is fungi green as
plants and
blue is animals and so what we
discovered is that the exposure
is very dynamic so it changes a lot from
one sample to the next
down below is clustering by sample types
of the plant samples
plant-dominated samples of the left
bacteria right next to that and brown
are the fungal ones
and so basically uh you can see what
kinds of exposures you're getting some
even for all for all three people they
expose expose them it's very very
dynamic
and it's fairly reproducible too though
so three times there's a monorail those
little arrows at the bottom
those are virtually always fungal
exposure so fungal exposures are quite
common
meaning they're they're the dominant
organism that you breathe
so then we went in one of the quantify
exactly what
is it that you're exposed to how much
comes from location how much from season
and so on and so forth
if you look at the on the left of my
samples you can see there's a trend for
the asian samples
to be clustered to the right is what's
something called a pca like plot
um and but the important point is we can
quantify it so for the items we can
measure
the major driver of your exposure for
the biologicals is location
but seasonal patterns that's the one
with the environmental circle
that's mostly season that actually is
pretty strong as well so
so location and season is very very
strong effect there is some technical
noise that contributes to this
so we actually looked at this in more
detail on this slide
and basically what we discovered is that
we took four people we sampled them over
the exact same month
and we looked at what their exposures
look like for biologicals
so in this case i'm actually the red
person the red dots are mine
and i travel a lot so my dots are a bit
scattered my sample's a bit scattered
the person who in light blue lives and
works across the bay
green is pretty close to me in a town
called sunnyvale a few miles away
and that dark blue is actually a person
who lives and works with purple
lives and works in san francisco
so the point out of all this is that
even though people
are in the same general area we all have
very very different exposures see the
green person and the
dark blue slash purple and the red we're
all very very different in our exposures
and not only that you can quantify where
those differences come from so
uh down below you'll see those are the
organisms that are
actually more prominent in the san
francisco samples so
you'll notice on the top ones the sludge
bacteria
is very very dominant in the san
francisco samples relative to the other
ones
if you've ever been to market street in
san francisco you understand this result
it makes a lot of sense
and then other things as well there are
pathogens in the samples they're very
very low levels
uh and it's unlikely they would cause
any issues
unless of course you maybe were
immunocomprised or something like that
so the point out of all this is that
they're very very strong location
patterns
okay um
it turns out that there's also um
strong seasonal patterns that's shown
here
so basically it turns out hundreds of
species have seasonal patterns and so
the green ones are the ones that peak in
spring
light blue and summer red and fall
and the the more dark blue ones are
actually peaking winter and some
examples are shown on the right so pine
peaks in late april um that was uh early
summer
well late april so yeah late spring
early summer
uh this fungus called turkey tail peaks
in late
uh fall early winter so comes up late so
so on and so forth you can find all
kinds of things and then you can
correlate these by the way with
biological effects and we've just
started that there's a lot more to do
here
one of the interesting correlations for
me was that i had mild allergies and
they correlated best with eucalyptus i
assumed they were always pine
in hindsight it made a lot of sense it'd
be eucalyptus which speaks roughly
around the same time as pine
the reason i probably should have
figured out before is that actually much
more allergic than california than i am
when i'm on the east coast which has
very little eucalyptus so
the bottom line is you can actually make
these interesting correlations
so we've also looked at the chemical
exposures and
just to give you a quick summary here
chemicals are also heavily influenced by
seasons and so
just two examples shown here uh
you know the top one tends to peak more
in in spring less in summer
the bottom one more in sorry winter
and lower in the spring and so on so you
can make these
one of the most important things we
learned about chemicals though is that
they're everywhere so there are plastics
everywhere
this is this uh compound you use to keep
insects off called d
that turns out to be in all the samples
that surprised me quite quite
reasonably abundant in those samples
pesticides are everywhere but they're
much more in some locations than others
carcinogens are also everywhere like
diathlon glycol and a few others so
again but they're in some locations a
much much stronger rigid location
is the number one driver of your
chemical exposure
there are some interesting patterns we
see this next slide just shows
um a chemical that correlates with
rain so you may know you can smell when
it's going to rain
that's because of that top compound
josephine which
uh it actually comes out of the ground
that's a volatile for the air pressure
drops when it's going to rain
and so what will happen is this compound
will come out of the ground you can
smell it
that's how you know it's going to rain
and everywhere where that bar is up that
was a rainy day
and it turns out pesticides also come up
they must be volatile coming out of the
ground as well would be my guess when
the air pressure drops when it rains
and other things like plastics go down
they probably
got washed into the ground with my
guests and so
those exposures are less when it rains
we also could correlate biologicals and
chemicals and this is one of the most
interesting results
it turns out we discovered there's an
anti-correlation
between fungal exposures and this nasty
chemical
called pyridine which is usually found
in paints than other locations
and so if you look at this slide here
the bottom row shows pyridine
when it's when and where it's most
prevalent and the upper row shows
shows the fungal species and you'll
notice
everywhere where pyridine is low fungal
exposures are higher
and everywhere where pyridine is higher
fungal exposures are lower so
we assume then that pyridine is probably
um
killing fungi and so this is actually
kind of useful to know because
maybe if you're allergic to black mold
you'd actually want to
have your house painted with a pyridine
based paint and you could actually keep
off the mold and that might be very nice
for you now you may die of cancer
because it's kind of an acid chemical
but nonetheless you get the idea
it's a potentially very useful thing to
know depending on your health situation
so we can actually take all this
information and assemble personal
exposure clouds this is mine
everybody has their own exposure so this
is mine
a lot of human-centric and
mammalian-centric species so
bacteria in your skin show up in these
exposed homes and stuff
and um but there's environmental ones as
well my house has a cat dog and used to
have a guinea pig and we picked up all
those sequences
inside the exposometer so we you can see
we know who has a dog in our study
because those dog sequences pick up
and you can see what plants and insects
and other things people are getting
exposed to now one of the coolest things
we do with all this data
is we bring it into a personal health
dashboard so
we we built the spent quite a bit of
time you even have an app that you can
enter certain
things that you're doing like your
health situation feeling good feeling
bad
but we can automatically pull in all
your wearable data as well as
upload clinical and other data types and
bring this right into your smartphone so
your smartphone i'm going to argue
will be your most important health
device in the future this thing
is going to be just as powerful possibly
more so than your doctor but your doctor
won't go away they'll still use this
that's the thing they can use it to help
manage your health better because it can
bring in all your information
and you can actually follow it the
different in the different data you can
enter different data types like heart
rate microbiome clinical labs and see
what it is you want to track and quickly
see what's going on and so the point is
that actually just like your car
dashboard
it gives you very relevant information
right at your fingertips
that you can use and you can act upon
should you so desire
and then the next slide as you say isn't
just for you
you can actually share it with your
physician and we think some of the data
that you get from your wearable is even
more accurate than what you'll get in
the doctor's office
and ultimately what i'd like to do is
see all these technologies brought
into healthcare and be able to better
manage people's health so
i'm a believer people will be getting
their genome sequence before they're
born
and then together with a more detailed
biochemical measurement so the so-called
omic measurements
and and sensor information we can better
manage people's health we can predict
disease risk better
catch disease early and again hopefully
manage
things so we can shift from sick care to
health care
really try and keep people healthier for
a much much longer time
i happen to have a very very amazing lab
that's shown here
so these folks in my lab are listening
to the left i won't have time to go
through all of them but when you shall
uh brian penning kevin contraposis uh
sofia rose i don't see her listed there
they were all very very powerful
in helping getting and studying started
and going we have amazing collaborators
george weinstock
uh helped very fantastic for the
microbiome work
tracy mclaughlin on the clinical side uh
people who built some of the personal
health dashboard to listen to the right
amir in particular and rush i wanted to
shout out to them expose them by the
team down below
and it's just been an amazing group of
people coming together to try and
transform the way we
currently do healthcare so thanks again
for having me here
uh happy to take any questions online
thank you dr snyder for the outstanding
presentation
for additional informative presentations
view our agenda
on our events page as a final reminder
our speaker will follow up with any
questions you have submitted
via email thank you again for your
participation